[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I was quite tyrannical I was known for
torturing a lot of people
this is my torture chamber
werewolves mummies and cobbled together
lab freaks have been around since the
earliest Decades of film but no monster
was perhaps more camera ready than the
vampire I mean those counts and Lords
who love to mug and Menace for the
camera Mesmerize with their fancy caves
and whose pale skin glows in the
Luminous flicker of old film cameras
[Music]
so no surprise that some of the best
vampire movies back then are some of the
best vampire movies now like Dracula
Nosferatu and vampire even as they
approach their Centennial anniversaries
that is the bar that's been set for our
guide to the best vampire movies and
still we found plenty worthy to follow
in their Fang steps
foreign
don't be frightened
I want this opportunity
how the hell did you do that
same as you do
a series of simple gestures
only I move too fast for you to see
across Legend we know vampires for their
Allure and seductive Properties or at
least just their property I mean who
wouldn't be Charmed by a 600 bedroom
Castle so if you are looking for
something to watch on your next open
coffin and chill night then go to bat
with our list of the best vampire movies
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thirst
sang Hyun a respected priest volunteers
for an experimental procedure that may
lead to a cure for a deadly virus he
gets infected and dies but a blood
transfusion of Unknown Origin brings him
back to life as a vampire now sang Hyun
is torn between faith and bloodlust and
has a newfound desire for teju the wife
of his childhood friend starring Sun
Kang ho Kim oakbin shin hakun and
directed by Park Chan wook critics say
the stylish thirst packs plenty of
bloody Thrills to satisfy fans of both
vampire films and director Park Chan woo
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number nine Kronos
antique dealer Jesus Chris stumbles
across Kronos a 400 year old Scarab that
when it latches onto him grants him
Youth and eternal life but also a thirst
for blood as Jesus enjoys his Newfound
Vitality he's unaware that a dying old
man Dieter de LaGuardia has sent his
nephew Angel to find the Scarab and
bring it back to him but Jesus will not
give immortality up easily even risking
the life of his orphan granddaughter
starring Federico Lupi Ron Perlman
Claudia Brooke and directed by Guillermo
del Toro critics say Guillermo del
Toro's unique feature debut is not only
gory and stylish but also charming and
intelligent
[Music]
you should follow me
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number eight Horror of Dracula on a
search for his missing friend Jonathan
Harker vampire Hunter Dr Van Helsing is
led to Count Dracula's castle upon
arriving Van Helsing finds an undead
Harker in Dracula's Crypt and discovers
that the counts the next Target is
Harker's ailing fiancee Lucy homwood
with the help of her brother Arthur Van
Helsing struggles to protect Lucy and
put an end to Count Dracula's parasitic
reign of terror starring Peter Cushing
Christopher Lee Michael Goff and
directed by Terence Fisher critics say
training Gore for Grandeur Horror of
Dracula marks an impressive turn for
inveterate Christopher Lee as a titular
vampire and a typical Hammer mood that
makes aristocracy quite sexy
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number seven Nosferatu 1979.
Jonathan Harker is sent away to Count
Dracula's castle to sell him a house in
Verna where he lives but Count Dracula
is a vampire an undead ghoul living off
of men's blood inspired by a photograph
of Lucy Harker Jonathan's wife Dracula
moves to Verna bringing with him death
and plague an unusually contemplative
version of Dracula in which the vampire
Bears a cross of not being able to get
old and die starring Klaus Kinski
Isabelle at Janny Bruno Gans and
directed by Werner Herzog critics say
stunning visuals from Verner Herzog and
an intense portrayal of the fame
bloodsucker from Klaus Kinski make this
remake of Nosferatu a horror classic in
its own right
hmm
the knife is old and could be dirty
it could give you blood poisoning
please let me do it it's the oldest
remedy in the world
oh forget it it's hardly worth
mentioning just a little cut
um
[Music]
are you you know
it's only for the best
[Music]
number six Dracula
The Dashing mysterious Count Dracula
after hypnotizing a British soldier
Renfield into his mindless slave travels
to London and takes up residence in an
old castle soon Dracula begins to wreak
havoc sucking the blood of young women
and turning them into vampires when he
sets his sights on Mina the daughter of
a prominent doctor vampire Hunter Van
Helsing is enlisted to put a stop to the
Count's never-ending bloodlust starring
Bella Lugosi Edward Van Sloan Dwight
Frye and directed by Todd Browning
critics say Bella lugosi's Timeless
portrayal of Dracula and this creepy and
Atmospheric 1931 film has set the
standard for major vampiric roles since
come
here
your will
is strong
and Helsing
more
wolf being more effective than wolf they
encounter
in jail
number five a girl walks home alone at
night
[Music]
residents of a worn down Iranian City
encounter a skateboarding vampire who
preys on men who disrespect women
starring Sheila vand Arash mirandi
Marshall Manesh and directed by Anna
Lily amirpor critics say a girl walks
home alone at night Blends conventional
elements into something brilliantly
original and serves as a striking
calling card for writer director Anna
Lily Amir poor
foreign
[Music]
foreign
number four what we do in the shadows
vampire housemates try to cope with the
complexities of Modern Life and show a
newly turned hipster some of the perks
of being Undead starring Johnny Bruff
Corey Gonzalez Mercure and Jermaine
Clement and Taiko watiti who also
directed the film critics say smarter
fresher and funnier than a modern
vampire movie has any right to be what
we do in the shadows is bloody good fun
you will not notice anything out of the
ordinary
no we certainly hope not let's just
let's just keep going
there guys how are you hey fellas
um is this the room of food all the
shouting coming from this is me yeah
okay we've had a couple of reports okay
there's a couple of people not that
happy about the level of noise
you put Neighbors on either side really
nervous I've got to touch those cops I'm
not a great hypnotizer so I could wear
off any second just guys don't kill
those buddies because it would mean more
police will come possibly even
Christians which is totally the last
thing we need in this house I can see
you having a good time end of the day
we've got to keep the uh the peace okay
see what I'm saying what's happening
you're joking
not a smoking lemon site no smoke detect
this way
rule number one
smoked sticks
number three vampire
after Alan gray rents a room near core
tempier in France strange events unfold
an elderly man leaves a packet on Gray's
table and shadows that are seemingly
alive lead him toward a castle at a
nearby Manor he Witnesses the same man
being murdered and gradually learns
about the curse of the vampire as gray
faces the horrors of the castle he
attempts to save the victim's daughters
one of whom Leon has fallen ill after
mysteriously being bitten starring
Julian West Henriette Gerard Yan Hye
ronimko and directed by Carl Theodore
Dreyer critics say full of disorienting
visual effects Carl Theodore Dreyer's
vampire is as theoretically unsettling
as it is conceptually disturbing
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
number two Let the Right One In
when Oscar a sensitive bullied 12 year
old boy living with his mother in
Suburban Sweden meets his new neighbor
the mysterious and Moody Eli they strike
up a friendship
initially reserved with each other Oscar
and Eli slowly form a close Bond but it
soon becomes apparent that she is no
ordinary young girl eventually Eli
shares her dark Macabre secret with
Oscar revealing her connection to a
string of bloody local murders starring
care heed Brandt Lena Lee Anderson pair
Ragnar and directed by Tomas alfredson
critics say Let the Right One In
reinvigorates The seemingly tired
vampire genre by effectively mixing
scares with intelligent storytelling
foreign
what's up
[Music]
all right
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions The Lost Boys
teenage brothers Michael and Sam move
with their mother to a small town in
northern California while the younger
Sam meets a pair of Kindred Spirits in
geeky comic book nerds Edward and Allen
The Angst ridden Michael soon Falls for
star who turns out to be enthralled to
David leader of a local gang of vampires
Sam and his new friends must save
Michael and star from the undead
starring Jason Patrick Corey Heim Diane
Wiest and directed by Joel Schumacher
critics say flawed but eminently
watchful Joel Schumacher's teen vampire
Thriller The Lost Boys Blends horror
humor and plenty of visual Style with
standout performances from a cast full
of young 1980 Stars come on guys looks
like it didn't let's head back huh they
put civil conference around here
someplace
there's nothing here let's go guys Jesus
[Music]
I thought they were supposed to be in
coffins
this game is it's one giant coffee
right now they're at the most vulnerable
remember you just have to get a leader
huh we don't know which one the leader
is
we'll just have to kill them all let's
start with the little first come first
state what was that a little vampire
humor wasn't funny
[Music]
no don't even
sucker
Interview with the Vampire
born as in 18th century Lord Lewis is
now a bicentennial vampire telling a
story to an eager biographer suicidal
after the death of his family he meets
Lestat a vampire who persuades him to
choose immortality over death and become
His companion eventually Genta Lewis
resolves to leave his violent maker but
Lestat guilt him into staying by turning
a young girl whose addiction to the
family breeds even more conflict
starring Tom Cruise Brad Pitt Antonio
Banderas and directed by Neil Jordan
critics say despite lacking some of the
book's subtler shadings and sufferings
from some clumsy casting Interview with
a Vampire benefits from Neil Jordan's
atmospheric Direction and a surfeit of
Gothic thrills foreign
[Music]
do you find this beautiful
magical
our white skin our Fierce eyes drink you
asked me do you have any idea of the
thing you will become
[Music]
no longer don't make me do this I cannot
do it to me
snatch me from my mother's hands like
two monsters in a fairy tale
and now You Weep
I haven't tears enough for what you've
done to me
you'll get her to me Louie
before you leave me
blade
a half mortal half Immortal is out to
avenge his mother's death and rid the
World of Vampires the modern day
technologically advanced vampires he's
going after are in search of his special
blood type needed to summon an evil God
who plays a key role in their plan to
execute the human race starring Wesley
Snipes Stephen Dorff Chris
Christopherson and directed by Stephen
Norrington critics say though some may
find the plot a bit lacking Blade's
action is fierce plentiful and
appropriately stylish for a comic book
adaptation
come on
yeah came back to finish you off get out
of my way you freak
[Music]
you out of your damn mind
[Music]
wow
and finally number one Nosferatu 1922.
in this highly influential silent horror
film The Mysterious count warlock
summons Thomas hutter to his remote
Transylvanian castle in the mountains
the Erie orlock seeks to buy a house
near hutter and his wife Ellen after
orloc Reveals His vampire nature hudder
struggles to escape the castle knowing
that Ellen is in grave danger meanwhile
orlock's servant knock prepares for his
master to arrive at his new home
starring Max Shrek Alexander granick
Gustav Von vangenheim and directed by
F.W more now critics say one of the
silent era's most influential
masterpieces nosferatu's Eerie Gothic
feel and a chilling performance from Max
Shrek as the vampire set the template
for the horror films that followed
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]